one of the many important federal
government positions that Donald Trump
has failed to fill in a timely manner is
that of a head of scientific research at
the US Department of Agriculture the
USDA
according to a leak Donald Trump has
finally selected someone from the job
but the bad news is who has been
selected under the 2008 farm act the
head of the USDA research arm is
supposed to be the sort of head
scientist for the agency chosen from
quote among distinguished scientists who
specialized or signatur have significant
experience in agricultural research
education and economics a good
credential to be selected to be the head
scientist in charge of research at the
USDA would be to be a scientist
Trump has instead chosen right-wing
Christian fundamentalist radio host Sam
Clovis for the job Clovis is not a
scientist in any sense but he did go on
television many times to defend Donald
Trump during the campaign so he's got
that going for him the USDA has this
huge list of really important scientific
responsibilities they study and make
policy on everything involving food
safety nutrition farming land
conservation and climate change climate
change by the way right-wing radio host
and Christian fundamentalist Sam Clovis
also happens to be a climate change
denier he is called climate change quote
simply a mechanism for transferring
wealth from one group of people to
another Clovis's educational background
is business and foreign policy he has no
experience in or education in food
safety or agriculture or nutrition he
has never taken a graduate level course
in any kind of science whatsoever the
head of science at the USDA is often
consulted on major scientific issues for
example like during the Obama
administration the lead researcher at
the USDA was in charge of advising the
rest of the government on Ebola and Zika
how is a guy who has never taken a
graduate level science class and has
credentials in business and being a
Christian fundamentalist going to advise
the government on how to deal with Ebola
or Zika just as a reference point the
person that Barack Obama appointed to
this job was a PhD scientist who had
previously served as the chairman of the
food and nutrition board at the
Institute of Medicine which is part of
the National Academy of Sciences you
know left at left wingers who were
educated it's all a big conspiracy to
indoctrinate our kids college is just a
left-wing and doctrine ation center
Clovis is also the person who introduced
the Trump campaign to Carter Paige who
is one of the most implicated people in
the Trump Russia scandal as far as the
public knows does any of this surprise
us anymore is this the new normal I sort
of feel like I've become desensitized to
these kinds of appointments and these
kinds of decisions in general and of
course this is exactly who you would
expect Donald Trump to choose to lead
the u.s. be a scientific division you'll
see some right-wingers online saying oh
this is really good Trump's draining the
swamp he's not doing the establishment
thing
breaking news folks instead of draining
the swamp by hiring non scientists to
science positions
what about draining the swamp by cutting
down on the lobbyists and the financial
industry cronies in your administration
instead of putting non scientists in
science positions maybe that's a little
crazy and as we know Donald Trump has
filled the swamp
he hasn't drained it the only non
establishment pics have been drastically
disturbingly under qualified people to
positions where you're supposed to have
actual credentials and I know a lot of
people on our reddit discussion forum
are very very concerned about this
understandably you can join the red
discussion forum and participate in this
and other conversations at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t today's
program is made possible in part by
Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s